we're ready for you your majesty three
two one being in one of the most
expensive shows on television definitely
has its perks when it comes to the
clothes IRL the Royals set the stage
when it comes to Fashion so Netflix's
the crown truly has its work cut out for
it when it comes to the show's fashion
and makeup let's take a look at all that
went into it number one the final season
already looks good the show has been
recreating some of Princess Diana's most
exciting looks some of the dresses being
included in the sixth and final season
of the crown are Diana's caring dress a
blue dress with bright flowers on it and
it was actually one of the princess's
favorites Diana's Egyptian visit Safari
style will be featured in which she
wears head to toe khaki in all its Chic
Glory actress Elizabeth Debicki who is
portraying Diana will be featured in a
powdered pink suit for the scenes where
she visits Bosnia and last but not least
the Revenge dress the dress Diana wore
when it was announced that she and
Charles were split thing The Prince and
Princess of Wales have decided to
separate a moment for the world and now
a major moment for our TVs number two
season five Fashions are thrilling as
ever a scene shot in Winchester England
saw Elizabeth Debicki layering a
Cerulean Blazer over a belted black
dress with a matching handbag and bumps
just like Diana did in September 1995 to
join Prince Charles dropping off their
eldest son at the elite Eaton College
Landing the look the tenant star also
wore a replica of the princess's
sapphire and diamond engagement ring on
her hand number three originality is key
to recreate the mother of all wedding
dresses costume designer Amy Roberts
collaborated with the original designer
David Emanuel although they didn't have
the original patterns Emmanuel talks the
Wardrobe team through the detail of many
of the original drawings to help them
create the Gown according to Netflix
three people spent 600 hours working on
the dress the wedding dress that took 4
watching
so think about that the next time you
have a project to complete and I didn't
but I felt a bit weird number four she
is the moment she is the mood when it
comes to creating looks for the crown
it's important to address the themes of
the season and go from there in season 4
Olivia Coleman's Queen Elizabeth II
wears slightly more somber colors to
reflect the less optimistic mood of a
broken Britain in the 1980s number five
more clothing more problems it's
complicated no it's not it's wicked and
it's cold-hearted as the character of
Princess Margaret moved from season
three to season four the clothing
shifted from party gowns and Sherbert
colors to more somber Earth Tones and
while there is some serious talent in
the fashion Department of the crown
actress Helena Bonham Carter who played
Princess Margaret took issue don't be
such a prick Bonham Carter admitted she
wasn't always happy with Margaret's
outfits throughout the series she
confessed the sheer quantity of new
costumes quickly became overwhelming
you know the actress said I don't think
I've ever been in something where I had
a new costume for each scene practically
who would have guessed that the toughest
part of the job would be putting on
clothes number six fast fashion fun fact
unlike these 600 hours that went into
Diana's wedding gown princess Margaret's
wedding dress was made in a week and
went on without a fitting apparently the
costumers didn't have the time to do it
any other way the dress is Iconic so the
costume team decided there was no point
in changing it they just needed to try
and capture the details accurately the
only drama that occurred with the
creation of this dress was occasionally
running out of claw quite the workplace
Hazard number seven are you a Jackie or
an Elizabeth the Kennedy's visiting
Buckingham Palace was one of the
highlights of season two of The Crown it
offered a Sumptuous Taste of the era
plus a heartfelt moment between the
monarchy and the president's family
[Music]
the Majesty Mrs Kennedy the Jackie
fashion moment on the crown was all in
the name of contemporary French fashion
greatly contrasting the Queen's stodgy
Persona the costume Department went
Sleek for Jackie lacking any additional
accessories to speak to The Elegant yet
simple modern aesthetic she exudes as
the first lady number eight it's all in
the contrast in order to make Jackie
Kennedy's outfits pop in all its modern
Glory the show made sure the queen made
the gaudy and old-fashioned dress choice
however both items were in blue to
parallel the leaders a glove and one did
have someone who hates attention as much
as I do the largest difference between
the two was that Jackie was sleek and
accessoryless and the queen was blinged
out to the nines number nine made by
hand nearly every bit of costuming on
the set of the crown had to be sewn and
assembled By Hand by all the
hard-working artists behind the scenes
every hat dress and suit had to be
painstakingly created from scratch to
capture the a specific time and place
the one outfit that was the soul costume
borrowed from an outside Source was the
coronation costume worn by Queen
Elizabeth
that piece was a recreation for an
exhibit by Swarovski it was commissioned
in 2012 for the real-life Queen's
Diamond Jubilee unlike the original
which was hand embroidered most of the
patterns on this dress were screen
printed and then adorned with beaded
accessories number 10. Securities got to
be tight while the show does its best to
make all the pieces authentic as far as
jewelry goes they tend to use replicas
of actual pieces of jewelry according to
the costume designer for the show Jane
Petrie she claims none of the jewels are
real adding that fake jewelry actually
looks better on screen the more you know
yes a lot of choice man that's one of
yours number 11. Stars they're just like
us during one of Princess Margaret and
Tony's motorcycle scenes the team had to
sneakily replace the bag the character
Margaret was using because the real life
actress Vanessa Kirby accidentally lost
it according to costume designer Jane
Petrie Vanessa insisted on taking her
handbag on the motorbike with her they
stopped somewhere and they rode back and
she lost her handbag on the way around
so by the time they got back there was
no bag and no earrings and she had no
phone so we obviously had to cheat thank
goodness for that Netflix budget number
12. it's a numbers game according to the
design team over 300 costumes were
assembled for the featured cast alone
for season one beyond that there were
around 7 000 extras over the season who
were also costumed each with at least
two to five costumes number 13. the
crown never misses an opportunity to
make cinematic moments even with
clothing an example of this is when
Queen Elizabeth in season 1 is landing
in England after her father's death
there is a crowd of politicians and
figureheads waiting for her looking more
like undertakers in their all-black
suits and top hats they are an imposing
crowd assembling like a murder of crows
ready to pick her apart chilling number
14 the most important job the costume
department is the largest apartment
within all the behind the scenes of the
crown and it shows not to mention a cast
favorite Department specifically by the
Olivia Coleman who played Queen
Elizabeth in season three and four it's
a huge team effort the queen has a
different outfit almost for every scene
and they're all handmade they are all
incredible number 15 the devil is in the
details as it's been mentioned hand
sewing garments on the set of the crown
is a must there is no shortcut in the
work all it takes is one look at
Princess Margaret's birthday dress with
individually attached butterflies to
know that they weren't messing around
costume designer Jane Petry claims
there's no cheating on beadwork when it
comes to Silk so remember there is no
crying in baseball and there is no
cheating with silk this has been an
in-depth look at all the costumes of
Netflix's the crown which style excites
you most drop us a comment below